your top military advisors warned
against withdrawing on this timeline
they wanted you to keep about 2500
troops no they didn't they were split
so no one no one told you we can do that
we can continue to do that no no one
said that to me that i can recall
biden said that we would still be able
to carry out the over the horizon
missions we needed to we'd have air
bases we'd be able to still monitor
terrorist traffic in afghanistan no we
won't i mean end of story no we don't
have any resources on the ground we have
no bases in country and we have no bases
anywhere nearby pakistan cut a deal with
the taliban to kick us out and russia is
denying us the ability to build any
bases or have a base anywhere nearby
the previously unreported exchange
between the u.s and russian leaders has
complicated the us military's options
for basing drones and other
counter-terrorism forces and countries
bordering land locked afghanistan that
challenge has deepened with the collapse
over the weekend of the afghan
government and armed forces
the exchange also indicates moscow was
more determined to try to maintain
central asia as a sphere of influence
than to expand cooperation with the new
american president over the turmoil in
afghanistan former and current u.s
official said uh yeah no no bleep
that there's a shock you mean the
russians aren't interested in helping us
who could have foreseen this cataclysmic
event
who could have foreseen that the
russians and the chinese and the taliban
might not be all that helpful to us in
fighting terrorism
without access to central asian nations
like uzbekistan kyrgyzstan and
tajikistan the us would need to rely on
bases in qatar other arab gulf states
and u.s navy aircraft carriers in the
indian ocean to fly aircraft to
afghanistan
flight times from the gulf states are so
long a u.s drone might spend more than
60 percent of its mission flying to and
from afghanistan from a u.s base in
qatar that would limit the time for
conducting reconnaissance or carrying
out strikes over the country because the
drones basically run out of fuel
so this is all going really really
really well the good news is that joe
biden is enamored with it he loves it he
loves it and when he's not lying about
how he got to this decision here's how
he got to the decision he woke up one
morning he had his can of insurer he
watched part of an episode of matlock
and then he farted out his decision
that's how he came to this decision
there's no logic to it he was told in
advance by pretty much everyone that
this was the world's worst decision he
was told by his dod that he needed to
leave some skeletal troops there at
least until the evacuation was complete
he was told by his state department this
was a mistake he was told by everyone
this was a bad idea but bad ideas have
never stopped joe biden before
that's kind of amusing when donald trump
was president there was all this talk
about how you know trump isn't really
running his administration the people
around him are running his
administration
and in reality many of the people around
trump were constant checks on his bad
ideas i very often trump would have a
bad idea militarily speaking like what
if we precipitously pulled that from
syria and james mattis would step in and
go you know mr president you can't do
that it's a bad idea and trump would go
okay fine and then he would listen
joe biden listens to no one and so his
advisors have just gone along with the
worst foreign policy decision in my
lifetime i just went right along with it
and enabled it after advising him it was
a terrible idea
there was no internal bucking there was
no there are no leaks to the press there
was no talk in advance about how this
was going to go
they just went along with it they let
the adult old man figure out what the
policy would be a policy that he had
locked in from 2010 and on even though
the war in afghanistan has radically
shifted since 2010 given the fact that
we radically downscaled our troop
commitment in afghanistan post 2014.
the united states has not had more than
12 13 000 troops in the country at any
time since 2014.
and at the time that we left we had 2
500 troops officially in country
to provide again a base from which to
fight terrorism
but joe biden at least he has sort of
these moments of refreshing honesty
because every so often it breaks through
and joe biden did this interview with
george stephanopoulos
in which he freely admits that whether
like he first tried to blame this on
trump you'll recall remember he said
this is oh trump had cut this really bad
deal in doha qatar with the with the
taliban and we had to abide by that deal
and now job is like yeah whether or not
that deal was made i was going to do it
which is the actual truth
would you have withdrawn troops like
this even if president trump had not
made that deal with the taliban i would
have tried to figure out how to withdraw
those troops yes because look george
there is no good time
to leave afghanistan
15 years ago would have been a problem
15 years from now
the basic choice is
am i going to send your sons and your
daughters to war
in afghanistan
in afghanistan in perpetuity okay so
when he says there's no good time to
leave afghanistan uh the answer to that
is
right which is probably why we should
have left some skeleton troops there at
a minimum
but he was committed to this he's
committed to this by the way there's
news breaking this morning the situation
in afghanistan is getting worse
according to sasha inberg who's a
national security reporter for nuzi
previously at npr and national
geographic a source says situation in
afghanistan is rapidly deteriorating
we've had americans get beaten
throughout the night one of them an
american woman was beaten twice even
though she was carrying a u.s passport
there are reports of sure chaos breaking
out again in afghanistan for all the
talk about how this thing is starting to
lock down it continues to be chaos
at the airport in afghanistan
it's it's a disaster area
and yes joe biden was warned about this
yes joe biden was warned about of course
he was
now joe biden lied about that right he
went on stefanopoulos and in the course
of about 30 seconds said he wasn't
warned about it and then realized that
that was going to be outed as a lie and
then he went to the i don't recall
defense right the i don't recall defense
in politics is what you do it's the
lawyerly way of avoiding any sort of
actual blame
because if you don't recall that can't
be argued with
and since everybody assumes that joe
biden has some form of memory loss
anyway it's actually credible here's joe
biden going from i was never told to i
don't recall in in the space about 30
seconds
your top military advisors warned
against withdrawing on this timeline
they wanted you to keep about 2 500
troops no they didn't it was split
that wasn't true
they didn't tell you that they wanted
troops to stay
no not at not in terms of whether we
were going to get out in a time frame
all troops they didn't argue against
that so no no one told your military
advisor did not tell you no we should
just keep 2500 troops it's been a stable
situation for the last several years we
can do that we can continue to do that
no no one said that to me that i can
recall no okay and you can tell he's
lying right there right he realizes he's
trapped himself and uh and that he's
lying uh in fact we know for a fact that
he was informed by many of his advisors
that this was a terrible idea this has
been widely reported in fact back in
april jensaki confirmed that some
advisors were telling biden to leave
troops right this is publicly
can you explain the rationale for why
president biden went against the advice
of military commanders who recommended
leaving 2500 troops on the ground in
afghanistan
well i think that's an over
characterization of every military
leader and i don't think they've all
provided their point of view no military
commander wants to stay forever they
insist that this is not some insist this
is not in time the time to leave some
opponents of his decision oh so some
have said it's not what so i was told
that that was not there was no
opposition to that
by joe biden right then right he doesn't
recall anybody saying that to him we now
have reports from the wall street
journal from the new york times from
pretty much every major media
publication saying that joe biden was
told by everyone up to and including by
the way lloyd austin his secretary of
defense as well as the wonderful mark
belly the chairman of the joint chiefs
of staff he was told by everyone this is
a bad idea anybody needed it anyway
because he's a stubborn old coot and he
has decided that his bad foreign policy
ideas need to be as as barack obama said
about joe biden don't underestimate
joe's ability to screw things up
yeah well the american people did and
now we're going to pay for it in a
pretty serious way
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang